will we see the Gold World return in the
new
series PA buddy we're just talking about
you all good where are they now what are
they doing and did they ever really lose
power or did they just switch tactics
with a new alliance welcome to SRA your
SciFi TV and mve a
[Music]
channel
the gal were a brilliant symbiotic
villain they were brilliant partly
because they could hide so easily they
were so clever they were so maniacally
evil well not really being evil for the
sake of being evil in a way but if I
succeeded the orai would have lost
interest in being on their merry way you
were going to save the Galaxy by
destroying pretty much everyone in it
they just genuinely believe they deserve
to be our
masters they were borderline psychotic
at times Anubis generally tried to kill
all of life even Thanos only tried to
kill half of
us I am
inevitable so the gold were a brilliant
villain but now they are defeated the
the system Lords are all gone on they
were basically defeated by sg1
repeatedly and then the replicators and
then the AI much of their technology was
then used by the Lucian Alliance and
others and their empire fell into
ruin so where are they now well there
are apparently a bunch of gold on earth
running major corporations and big
businesses watched over by the nid these
gold World continue their Lust For
wealth and power just using our
capitalistic system to do it to be
honest I can sit here and think of
several top Executives that probably
would be go W one of them owns uh now he
might be a gold but to be honest the
decline of the system lorded started
probably before sg1 really got involved
obviously they defeated raw and then
they defeated apus like five or six
times but as we got to know the system
Lords better people like Emperor Yu who
was already in serious to cine he was
just basically so old and been in the
sarcophagus so many times he basically
got a Gold version of dementia and
apparently the gold were actually eating
other symbiot to try and extend their
own lives we found out that actually
there hadd been zero population growth
within the gold for some time they were
a species already decaying already dying
out we just help them along a little bit
as I say though it was really the battle
with the replicators that completely
annihilated them even though we then
defeated him using the super weapon with
darara their forces were massively
depleted by the end of that conflict a
lot of their systems had already fallen
and the Lucian Alliance had already
started to get a foothold in those areas
band of Smugglers and criminals and ex
slaves had started to group together and
form this Alliance they'd already
started to acquire a lot of Go
technology and really it was the power
vacuum Left Behind as the system Lords
fell one by one that gave them the power
to actually become a threat within the
Galaxy then the aai invasion just
finished off anything the gold had left
B being one of the final system Lords to
fall but as we are expecting a return to
the Stargate Universe in a new movie and
then hopefully Series where do we think
the gold are now are they still just
hiding on Earth and around the Galaxy
well I would have thought the Jaffa
Nation would have a little bit to say
about that the Jaffa have been enslaved
by the gold for thousands of years and
they're not very happy about it now they
have found their freedom and dismissed
the old gods I could see them as they
organized themselves as they really
become a power within the Galaxy
themselves that they would probably seek
some kind of Retribution that any gold
world out there that was still sort of
being sneaky they would probably try to
hunt them down almost like Europe
following World War II where the Nazis
were hunted down and put on trial I
could see the Jaffer demanding the same
thing if there were gold War on Earth
loing up pretending to be all big and
powerful bosses of certain conglomerates
Elon I actually think they would turn up
and demand those gold be arrested and
demand those gold be put on
trial that's if they allow it to go to
trial because they might just demand
that they're and killed instantly but
like we saw in a couple of epodes of sg1
where te turned upon planets and then
was actually blamed for the crimes he'
committed while apus was his
master perhaps the Jaffer would then
demand similar retribution I can see the
Jaffa Nation alone has probably by now
hunted the gold to the point of
Extinction but there is one thing that
I've always wondered how did the Lucian
Alliance build up so much power so
quickly they actually became a threat to
the T now I know they had more ships
they basically acquired all of that go
technology and they learned to use it
really quickly the Gold World
traditionally had kept their human
slaves down on their knees refusing to
allow them to even believe that their
technology was anything more than magic
but the Lucian Alliance had learned how
to use much of this technology very very
quickly they were using all of the ships
they were using all of the transport
they were using things like the scanning
technology that was used to Target and
then track sg1 they attacked the eus
base and were successful they attacked
Destiny and were successful they were
planning to attack Earth and really were
nearly successful they'd used gold
brainwashing technology on Telford and
had got away with it it was only really
through look that we defeated them how
did the Lucian Alliance get so
formidable so quickly was it just
because of the power vacuum left behind
by the go W or is it maybe that there
was actually a shadowy force behind the
Lucian Alliance the go world as we've
already said can hide in plain sight how
do we know the go world didn't just
switch tactic now there's actually an
old story that the Roman Empire here on
Earth never fell it just got bored of
being attacked all the time so turned
itself into the Catholic church and
continued to rule Europe for another
thousand years I'm wondering if the goal
did something similar they would knew
they were under attack they knew they
were threatened they knew their enemies
were at the doors so they reinvented
themselves they stepped behind the
curtain and they became the Lucian
Alliance perhaps that's how the Lucian
Alliance got so formidable so quickly
that's how they seem to be able to use
gold technology like Masters that's how
they were able to get so much
intelligence for example knowing where
the icus base was in the first place
obviously that was Telford but you know
what I mean I'm wondering are the go W
actually still a major power in the
universe we just know them as the Lucian
Alliance
now it's a thought so guys tell me what
you think would the Gold World now be at
the point of Extinction could they still
be a threat remembering how just damn
intelligent and bloody evil they were or
as or actually is it possible that
they're still our Puppet Masters but
this time they've stepped behind the
curtain and they're actually playing
with the strings of maybe the Lucian
Alliance I wonder get into the comments
and tell me exactly what you think and
i' also love to know when Stargate
returns will we see the gold again tell
me what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
a day before everyone else and without
the adverts on YouTube can't say fairer
than that you can also go to
c.co which is our dedicated website and
we do articles based on on most of our
videos and we try and add a little bit
more information for you to digest go
and check it out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time